así hay muy buenas tardes pues es el fin
de esa visita de emanuel bach con aquí a
sando en y acaba de terminarse es andoni
que es un suburbio en el norte de parís
un suburbio de clases populares que
durante esa primera vuelta votó en un 60
por ciento porque son luís me lanzó ni
tan sólo 16 por ciento por emanuel ama
con el presidente-candidato vino aquí a
decir que no había que normalizar pues
que la extrema derecha esté siempre
digamos en la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones como ya ha ocurrido en el
2017 y ahora en esta elección ha
presente el estuvo acompañado por el
alcalde de esta localidad que es un
alcalde socialista que que junto con
otros 14 alcaldes del departamento que
es el as en sandoná han escrito una
carta pidiéndole a los electores de todo
este departamento que voten problemas no
el macom para ponerle digamos para
detener la extrema derecha y evitar que
imagino lo pena y llegue al poder la
idea de esta visita era por una parte
bueno es la primera vez que manuel marco
en esta campaña presidencial viene a
unos de los otros
a veces estas clases populares olvidadas
por parte de la campaña y muchas veces
también pues esta imagen de presidente
de los ricos pues es de esas imágenes
que son digamos lo que más piensa la
gente aquí pero él fue recibido más bien
con aplausos muchísimos curiosos que
estuvieron aquí escuchando lo que él
vino a decir y bueno pues ya terminando
también esta campaña a 34 días de esa
segunda vuelta mañana será ese último
evento de campaña en el sur de francia